donc la voyez on retrouve cette petite
découpe l'île-des-soeurs des écrans
toujours plus grand
[Musique]
troisième jour se laissent franchement
fatigue et la sai on est jeudi
c'est plusieurs journées quand même à
travailler sortir monte à ça c'est dur
mais bon c'est pas grave
allez on y va pour cette nouvelle jambe
aujourd'hui on est au csa vegas
troisième jour ça va envoyer du bois je
sais pas quelle vidéo je vais faire
aujourd'hui on va les voir à l'intérieur
ce qui se passe on now comme agent
center enfin matin se passe
et bah écoute presser presser dans les
bureaux les gens prennent il est hyper
fin on fera les comptes en weppes et toi
tu as et vous partez dans des piscines
et va bosser un peu commencé ça et voilà
de retour au paradis hausse est ce là
c'est le petit stand de samsung
c'est un peu un musée de samsung avec
plein de produits qui sont sortis par
passer en un peu de voyager dans le
temps regardez seul l'impact du samsung
galaxy s 10 aura lieu le 20 février
prochain à san francisco et non pas au
mwc mais il sera forcément présenté
quelques jours après un double échec
et puis il y aura aussi probablement de
levelt à paris on ira boire directement
nouvel obs sur le stand de hisense avec
un smartphone c'est le hisense eu 30 au
clavier on retrouve cette petite des
couples désert des écrans toujours plus
grand jean plus d'immersion pour le
multimédia
vous avez l'écran de 6,30 pousse la
résolution cdu fhd plus c'est l'écran au
infiniti je trouve qu une alternative
qui est assez intéressant talent koch
s'est pas complètement parfait pour le
moment mais c'est pas mal c'est en tout
cas le mérite d'exister on essaie de
trouver des solutions qui sont vraiment
intéressants pour éviter d'avoir des
grosses encore chaude et pourquoi pas la
petit bout d'os qui était pas la pire
solution ça reste quand même pas parfait
c'est pas idéal mais en tout cas on voit
qu'on avance et que petit à petit jeu
direct loggia finir par disparaître bon
la luminosité est pas mal l'écran est
assez sympa à l'intérieur cette machine
qu'est ce qu'on a on a un qualcomm
snapdragon la série 6 1 675 deux
versions 6 giga de ram avec 128 giga de
stockage ou alors 8 gigas de ram avec
128 giga de stockage vous avez à
l'arrière un petit capteur d'empreintes
digitales vous vois c'est facilement la
position alors je suis pas hyper fan
parce qu'on vient quand même gratter
avec le petit module photo avec le flash
led
après ce que j'aime pas sur ce design
sont modèle de hisense c'est le côté
cuir je trouve ça vraiment rococo très
cheap poste vous avez le logo est saine
sur le côté bouton pour l'allumer pour
l'éteindre
bouton de volume et de l'autre côté on a
un bouton qui est dédié en fin de compte
à l'appareil photo
ça permet d'arriver directement dessus
ça c'est pas mal alors justement parlons
photo vous avez un double module ici 48
mégapixels + 5 mégapixels mais 5
mégapixels va vraiment être là en terme
de renforts pour le mode portrait et à
l'avant et une caméra self ici de 20
mégapixels pour faire tourner tout ça on
a une énorme batterie de 4500 millan
perreur vous dit pour le déverrouiller
vous êtes 14 empreintes digitales mais
vous avez aussi fashion locke et on
tourne là dessus sur un android 9 bail
avec la surcouche c'est visionne une
il a également de la recharge rapide
ceylac wild charge 4 alors sur le mode
photo
on a de l'intelligence artificielle ou
là c'est très bizarre
mode beauté photos vidéos et textes mode
saas et pour reconnaître du texte devait
même le mode panorama envoyé on a plein
de photos que les gens nous ont fait
alors qu'est ce qu'on a comme photo lors
d'un petit air avec des joueurs c'est
assez rigolo
pourquoi pas bon il n'y a rien de bien
vous fout hein je suis passé notre côté
que ce soit vraiment le photophone du
siècle doit y avait un truc qui est un
peu fou mais c'est pas terrible c'est
très flou voilà bon c'est un petit
smartphone un peu rigolo on va vraiment
qu'en tout cas ces écrans infiniti haut
avec ses petites des couples à va y
avoir de plus en plus en 2019
qu'est ce qui va arriver plus tard
est-ce que la caméra va carrément
disparaître sous l'écran c'est ce que
j'espère en tout cas que c'est vraiment
intéressant pour le multimédia et c'est
en tout cas c'est un point qui est
vraiment cool et si vous avez une petite
prise directe plutôt pas mal alors je
vois pas je pense que c'est de l'usb
type c mais si je me mets à le
débrancher il va sonner je rentre même
pas comment haut parleur mono sur le
côté ce smartphone n'est dispo en europe
à partir du mois de mai j'ai pas le
tarif
euros milla coûte à peu créé 500 dollars
bon je pense qu'on peut arriver autour
des 450 euros hors taxes pour ajouter
ensuite l'intention de tva à mon avis
550 euros 600 euros c'est à peu près le
prix du web + 6 t à sa sortie c'est
qu'on risque d'avoir dites moi ce que
vous en pensez est ce que c'est un
produit qui pourrait vous intéresser
est ce que vous pourriez aller dessus
est ce que vous pourriez acheter est-ce
qui vous tente voilà on dit tout ça et
puis comme ils viennent même décroché à
l'instant je vous confirme qu'on a de
l'usb type c'est juste là pour la
recharge
donc ça c'est franchement super coup
voilà vous me dites ce que vous en
pensez on en reparlera de ce produit
jolie dans les gants de license prendre
quelques contacts pour qu'on puisse
rester connectés et en discuter dites
moi ce que vous en pensez en bas en
commentaire est ce que c'est un truc que
vous pourriez acheter
oui non on va là pour marquer tout ça et
puis on en reparle très bientôt
donc là on est sur les normes stand de
qualcomm il ya plein plein plein plein
de trucs ici forcément on va parler 5g
leur qualcomm on en reparlera quand même
un peu plus tard lorsqu'on sera au mwc
on va parler de la 5g l'on va également
parlé du nouveau soin dragonne 855 ça
c'est là qu'on fait qu'il faudrait que
j'ai alors j'ai pas exactement celle là
mais gh5 et je pense que franchement ça
pourrait être super cool au studio c'est
l'impression qu'un appareil nikon qui a
passé un mauvais moment alors laissant
les normes stand de samsung
bon si on parle de bigby on parle de 5 g
il ya l'écran qu'on accueillait dernier
aux rôles allait aussi toute une partie
concernant les portables il n'y avait
pas qui était pas un instant de l'année
dernière donc là vous avez toute la
partie pour les smartphones note 9,6 à
tout l'espace galaxy bon voilà il y
avait un truc hyper intéressant on parle
de cul la nuit quand on parle de plein
de choses
donc tout ça on en reparlera parade
samsung très prochainement ces instants
qui vraiment toujours
très très impressionnant
on est sur le stand de mercedes et ça c
est je dirais leur vision en tout cas
peut-être juste un proto de la voiture
du futur voiture qu'il dépassera seule
voiture complètement autonome regardez
la forme du truc vous n'avez absolument
aucun conducteur tout ce pilote
complètement automatiquement et regarder
l'intérieur c'est juste a eu sinon vous
avez des écrans gros si on avait gazon
forcément tout de suite on est dans le
côté un peu roulettes
mais le truc est juste ou si si ça c'est
complètement what the fuck ça c'est
l'hélicoptère du futur c'est le drone du
futur pour le transport aérien dans une
ville vous parle vraiment de transport
dans la ville
regardez vous prenez place à bord de ce
qui ressemble à un drone hélicoptère
c'est vraiment aimé landre rentrer
dedans
le truc complètement hallucinant
regardez là vous avez bel qui seul à
voler dans les ca va vous laisse assez
hallucinant donc à ces officines de
pilotes
[Musique]
cette classe est complètement
hallucinant passera pas compte que c'est
nouveau
moyen de transport c'est moins de
transports du futur du cas ça a
probablement remplacé l'hélicopère les
hélices
atteint du truc c'est complètement fou
[Musique]
deux véhicules c'est un taxi en fait
c'est un taxi volant c est le hub heures
du futur permettra de se déplacer dans
les villes c'est la nouvelle mobilité
urbaine
c'est intéressant
[Musique]